Atlanta Falcons head coach Dan Quinn
back here on the show how are you coach
Quinn rich what's up man I'm doing good
we're had one big Ford a block with guys
and then we're back at it again today
rain today so a good day for us outside
goings before we play inside so we need
some of this work when it comes so yeah
I'm pumped to be on with you guys I prom
to have you here it's just I guess you
know in radio too sometimes you will you
give the time so you're it's 20 minutes
after now right now right you still on
that clock got that right and so that's
all I want to do is to see if we get
through a good day today good practice
today battle for it we'll worry about
the you know stuff down the line later
on but it's been a good focus for the
guys so far rich the number of these
guys have played together for a few
years and really you know we'll push one
another understand the expectations for
each other so we're off to a good start
we got a lot of work to do but it is
good to be back in and out in the field
is where where we make us so we're gonna
put it in I love it so again you still
have that clock where we do every number
says now now o clock now it's that and
again this that idea is again you just
don't look over the steering wheel just
focus on the rep the the down the
distance the moment right yes all we can
control and other stuff you know like
there's playtime or where I'm at on the
depth chart or any that man that's out
of your control like all you can do is
like your effort your mindset to push
one another and so that part's good you
know and there's a good group of leaders
searchers Richie know so many of these
guys that'll you know take these young
guys and help guide them and push in and
that's been a good start to camp so the
fact that Julio Jones is now a happy
camper and and the quarterback signed
your signed I mean so many I know your
left your tackle sign I mean does that
make a job easier for you coach it does
because you know these guys who really
put it in when you're able to reward
them for a job well done it's a good
feeling now you wish you could do it for
everybody we know that's not the case
however those are the tough decisions
between Thomas and myself and Arthur
that we got to make but let's hope that
we're having for years to come having to
make those tough decisions I had once
said the Richard the only guys they have
we have 80 million we made some big
mistakes max and in cap room let's make
sure we're
developing the guys that are here and
when you get a chance to resign them out
it's a really good sign for you know
what they represent for the team and
year two now of this offense you know
post Shanahan what improvements can you
expect to be made on that front coach
during the off-season rich we had a big
you know kind like an audit you know you
do after and saying this area what went
well what you know didn't and so you say
okay what do you need to stop doing what
we start doing and what do we need to do
different that was kind of the basis for
where we started I'd say 80% of what we
do going into year four is a lot of the
same you know the scheme and the
technique we like wide zone run game and
the play-action and the keepers that go
with that so we want to make sure that
always stays connected to the philosophy
that's also who our guys Scout to you
know to make sure they fit into the
system so the tweaks we spend a lot of
time in the red zone to make sure that
part of our game could come back to
where we wanted it to that's where so
much of the scoring takes place and then
the other emphasis which I like from a
team standpoint it's our emphasis back
on the football we actually were in the
- last year in a turnover margin and
it's hard to play good football and be
in the mines that's been at the front of
our thinking as well well you know if
you bear with me coach Quinn on behalf
of all those who have Julio Jones and
their fantasy leagues how about just
throw it to 11 inside the 20 yard line
just oh you know what all of those who
are part of yours and others yes you
know that's just good coaching and
they'll also be good to know that he has
put work in and the aggressiveness to
shape and how he's in tell you and other
members of that group that he looks
great Dan Quinn Falcons head coach thank
you for that here on the Rich Eisen show
look we've already established that it's
now a clock for you it's now it's now
it's now and I know that what happens in
other camps I have nothing to do with
you but even Bill Belichick being asked
about what happened with Malcom Butler
last year and in Seattle your old spot
with Richard Sherman having left if
fully admitting with Cliff Averill as
well as what happened in the Super Bowl
then was something that they dealt with
for years and years and years the butler
interception how about your
Super Bowl experience coach and and what
you think about and what you think some
of your players are thinking about that
even two years later sure I definitely
recognize the question rich and for
those who've played for Championships
they know how much you know fun that is
to get the opportunity to do that so
I've been on sides when it's gone like
you want it and on the other side where
it hasn't and I hope that you get
yourself into some of those same
scenarios again where you have a chance
to prove what you've learned and anytime
you go through some adversity
it does make you harder in terms of you
know what lessons did I learn and you're
hopeful that as you grow from it and you
gain more experience okay that right
there that's we're gonna try like hell
not to have that instance whatever the
lesson might have been like whether it's
the game or not there's lessons to be
learned and how you you know respond to
those I think it's a big thing so I do
love that our team is a resilient group
and I would say one of the you know
factors that when you go through a
devastating loss there's uh some
toughness and some hardness gained and
this is a really tough and resilient
group of guys so each year is different
because not everybody is on the same
team every year so it's not like you
bring it up and talk about it but for
the men that went through that
experience you hope you gain some
lessons and then you apply them when
when those moments come again and then
in the camp of the current defending
Super Bowl champion Eagles a story came
out this week that officials from the
NFL were in camp going over the new use
of the helmet rule that has been put
into place and there was an even a
disagreement amongst the officials were
there as to what constitutes an illegal
hit in the 2018 season can do you know
what constitutes and do you think you've
been able to communicate to your team
what is a hit and you know like at the
end of it and if you were walking down
the street to say okay we're gonna make
sure the helmets not used as a weapon I
think that's easy to say and forever
we've all taught you know keep our head
up you know and when we're entering into
contact so sometimes those disagreements
and I wasn't there to experience but
sometimes dialogue that takes place
maybe it forced some clarity and another
way to say let's go back and revisit
again with that team maybe some
questions came up
you know amongst team members that they
need to talk you know through their
locker room to get it right and so I
don't mind dialogue and I don't mind
disagreements at times because that's
kind of I think how you grow doesn't
mean you have to be always you know in
disagreement but it does mean like
that's kind of how we learn so I wasn't
there - I did hear that you know the
officials were there and like they're
going to all camps but I do encourage
players and we've gone through some for
ourselves here let's save that place
let's show to the rest let's save that
play let's show to the rest that way we
can put a you know another clip on
another video clip on to say how is this
going to be called and as long as I
think everybody knows the rules of
engagement how something is going to be
officiated and then by the same token
from the coaching side how is it going
to be taught I think when those two
things you know become in alignment you
know it makes it more clear for everyone
so I mean obviously a disagreement in
terms of you with your staff and the
players and hashing it out that's one
thing but a disagreement between
officials let's just say it happens on a
third down and a few Thursday's and in
Philadelphia when you think your team's
off the field and and suddenly it's a
fresh set of downs for for the Eagles is
there no concern by you that the
officials are not on the same page here
for sure they are and let's hope that
you know the exhibition season is an
important one not just for players and
not just for coaches but for referees
and for officials to to make sure that
okay here are some new things going in I
want to see it live and how would we
call that so I think over the next you
know month or so Richard to be important
month for the NFL from a rule standpoint
players coaches referees and get that
full speed action that we all like and
we have some officials come into our
camp over the next few days and I love
when they're here because not only is it
you know real crisp in terms of you know
fouls or not but also that the players
have an understanding of what they're
looking at and how they would call it so
those are always a good day so even
though there were some disagreements I'm
sure there was some a lot of good that
came from their trip to Philadelphia I
know you're you're from the Mariucci
family coaching tree coach so I mean
Sydney says much would say bummer
loves telling that story tall Giants
fans bummer yeah and no I hope not on
the other end a bummer
no I think you know like that's what
it's for you know that when there's new
rules and new things to make the game
better man they have to iron some things
out in the preseason to get connected on
that's cool with me and I think the
catch rule is another step in the right
direction me too that's clearly define
okay it's you know the securing of the
catch two feet down or a body part and a
football moves when I explain that to
the team that felt good and they had one
so I've gone back through ones that were
incomplete before what is this and to a
man they could say catch fumble
incomplete catch so we just try to test
them and educate him and I also want to
know I think they'll be more catches
rich and I think there could be more
catches and fumbles I and I think that's
I'm so much better than then then no
catch when everybody sitting in a bar or
in your stadium or any stadium knows
that it's a catch I think I'm just
concerned that this new helmet rule is
going to be the catch rule of 2018 I
don't think so because I think it's what
they're trying to get rid of is the hits
that when you're in that same bar like
man that was an ugly hit and if we all
were saying that one if we could get
some of the ugly hits out I think we'd
all be in favor for that so I would
assume that it be more under that line
because what we don't want to do is make
the game even harder for the referees
and the officials there under a tough
spot as it is as fast as the game moves
and the players are so I'm hopeful that
there's some hits out there that we were
like I said if you're in that bar and
watching it that maybe those five or ten
and a year could go away and make the
game better let's do that why the reason
why I brought up mariachi in enclosing
here coach is because he he would know
the names of the refs their wives their
kids he could personalize the very
crucible moment of trying to get a call
in his favor during a game do you have
that that's a competitor no I would
probably have more expletives associated
which does but you know you do want to
know the guy so you have a you know a
good communication system with them and
most of the time the ref
Riis are the ones that you know come
over and we'll give you the information
of what it happens and I'm in favor of
those guys getting you know full time
opportunities where they can you know
help work with the staff so I think
moving some referees into some full-time
spots I think that was a big step by the
NFL and I think that's one that's better
for the officiating department and in
turn which makes it better for the
league last one for you I'm gonna ask
the question I asked to every coach who
has the ability to coach in the last
game of a year and the only coach who
has the ability to coached last game
here in his own house do you bring out
to your team flat out we can play for
the super bowl in our own home this year
you talked about it
no we don't talk about it only because
weather like it's such a cool moment
wherever your average and so for us
knowing that there's like this division
man like it is a legit division the NFC
South so what we try to put our focus on
even through the offseason like the
games that we battle against New Orleans
and Carolina and Tampa twice a year
going for it that's where our focus has
to be first because if you don't go down
that road first it makes it real
difficult to look you know too far down
so that is I'm surprised even asked
honestly knowing that we have a now
clock you can't blame a guy for trying
I mean it's your beautiful house I've
never been there by the way I look
forward to being there you do need to
get here and oh yeah you know there's
lots to do and we'd love to have you
down here any time man so all is good
here and hope to see you guys soon
no I know you got that that sort of
semicircle system of screens you could
put my entire 40-yard dash on there I
know you run the stadium before games so
we could do that coach thinks to call
appreciate it we'll chat soon yeah you
got Dan Quinn at Falcons DQ the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience